Wesley's with us in California hi Wesley
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hello
Dave thank you for taking my call
my pleasure how can I help so I've been
following your advice for a couple of
months now I'm relatively fresh but
what's going on is my fiancee of seven
years just gave birth to our second son
first son is six years old and in those
six years we racked up about 25 27k of
credit card debt it's all in her name
I've got about 3k that I let go after my
he was born but they've stopped hounding
me for it I'm trying to set up a budget
now I work full time bringing in about
27 K and just can't seem to get the
budget to click properly need some
advice from you does she work outside
the home she's a stay-at-home mother you
have a fiance for seven years she's the
one that's been putting off marriage
because she's afraid of taking that next
step forward and babies that's wild man
okay cool
all right just I'm sorry man painter get
off the ladder okay so what I would do
is put you on a every dollar budget it's
completely free all right hello okay and
I've already done that okay good so
you've got it all written out every
month you're doing that are you going
over that with her yes we're I'm slowly
starting to get her to come around and
get on the plan as well because we're I
don't like having to be the sole
provider and just not know where the
money's going so I want both of us on
board with the plan amen
well y'all don't make much money so you
got to really make it stretch I mean a
family of four with if you were married
a family of four with twenty with two
children making 27,000 in California is
probably right at the poverty line yeah
and luckily we don't have any rent to
pay because we're living with her family
which is a toxic environment but at
least
helps us save some cost there yeah okay
so how old are you I am 28 and what city
do you live in
I live in Marysville which is just
outside Sacramento area okay all right
and what is your long-term career goals
that honestly I don't even know what I
would like to do I just see myself
jumping from job to job until I find
something that sticks and being able to
provide for my family okay well um I've
got a son that's your age he's 28 okay
and so I'm thinking of him right now
and I was thinking I'm thinking if he
was in this situation and he sat down
said dad and have a cup of coffee what
do you think about this okay here's what
I would tell him there's a lot of
statistical correlation between people
winning with money and their overall
quality of life in getting things in the
right order about getting married and
having kids you got some of that out of
order already so let's get that
corrected this is what I would tell my
own son okay you do what you want to do
I'm not trying to hurt your feelings I'm
not trying to be mean to you I'm saying
I love my son and this is what I would
tell him okay then the second thing I
would say is you're starving to death
and you're living in a toxic environment
that you're forced to live in because
you're starving to death and so you
desperately need to start setting some
goals and having some clear vision for
your life on your career side because
where you live is not an inexpensive
place to live and you don't make any
money I'm not picking on you I'm not
talking down to you but you know dude
your life would change dramatically if
you made $75,000 a year obviously you
know that and so what are we gonna do
and let's spend some real energy some
some quiet time on the back porch with a
cup of coffee and even if you have to go
the neighbors because there is no quiet
time in this toxic house sit on the back
porch with a cup of coffee somewhere
and go okay God what am I gonna do so
that when I'm 42 or I'm 28 now when I'm
38 I'm well on my path to you know to
earning a considerable amount more in
something that I enjoy doing and that
I'm gifted at doing what is that and you
kind of have to brainstorm that and pray
that through and just have some quiet
time and you know watch the mist roll
off the river or whatever and and kind
of get this dialed in but you you know I
used to go down to my lake house for
instance and take a yellow pad and just
spend a day with me and God walking
around just talking to the talking to
him and what do you want me to do this
year what do you let me do next year
what do you want to do what do you want
me to do ten years from now and thinking
out into the future because you can get
caught up in the day-to-day
diaper-changing
and the day-to-day crazy mother-in-law
stuff and all of a sudden you look up in
another decade is gone and you're
sitting exactly where you were you got
to do something that gives you a vision
and pushes you out into the future and
start setting some career goals because
a lot of what I'm hearing from you is
you know mathematically you're not doing
a horrible job with the money you have
coming in you just don't have much
coming in and I'd love for you to have a
plan that says I want to be one of those
and I'm gonna go study these three
things so that I can be one of those and
I'm gonna get about that business
because that gets me out of my
mother-in-law's house that gets us in a
position that we get rid of this debt
all these old bad debts I can go back
and clean them up I can really get my
life my freakin life together here but
it's going to require a very careful and
intentional series of steps if you
continue to do the same thing over and
over again and expect a different result
that's the definition of insanity I'm
gonna jump from job to job the job and
hope this works out it's not gonna work
out it's not gonna work out you need a
path and I'm gonna fight and I'm gonna
scratch and I'm gonna claw and I'm gonna
grind and I'm gonna hustle to work that
path and that's gonna get me there and
that'll change your life that'll put you
into classes to take certifications to
take degrees to get that'll put you into
mentorship programs or printers ship
programs it'll put you into all kinds of
things that because
that's what it takes to go that path and
you ask yourself what has to be true
that's not true today to be one of those
when I'm 38 and then get about that
business and sir that'll change your
life because you have all of these
negative variables controlling you right
now and I really really want for you
that you get to control all these
variables instead of this lack of money
the bad career the bad housing situation
by old bad debt all of this is pounding
you and I want to get you up on top of
it where you're pounding it and you're
making it behave
that's what coffee would sound like
between me and my son if he came in with
your exact set of problems and I would
tell him to paint or get off the ladder
I really would because I just did